not able to participate today uh i wish
him a full and speedy recovery
our first witness is shirley webber uh
she is a california secretary california
secretary of state
position she has held since december of
2020 a newbie
she previously served as a member of the
california state assembly representing
the 79th assembly district
including portions of san diego after
having been elected in 2012.
before that she served on the san diego
board of education as a professor of
african-american studies at san diego
state university
she received her phd in communications
as well as her master's and bachelor's
degrees from
ucla secretary weber you are now
recognized for five minutes
thank you very much and i want to thank
the chairman adler
chairman cohen and the ranking member
johnson
as well as thank congresswoman jackson
lee for inviting me to be with you this
morning
as pointed out i am currently the
secretary of state for the state of
california the first african-american
who's ever held that position in 170
year history
of the state of california uh and so i
come to you today
as the author also last year when i was
in the assembly
of ab3121 our reparations bill
for us in california we are very clear
that we need not ask
whether there are not slavery has had an
impact
but instead illuminate the extent to
which it has had an impact
uh we are through ab 3121 which is law
in california
have a staff are establishing the task
force to study and develop
reparations proposals for african
americans
it will consist of experts who study
slavery's impact
education educate californians uh
compile a report of their findings
and provide information and
recommendations to our legislature
as to what we need to do to repair the
damage done as a result of slavery
the body that will exist the task force
it will encompass
experts in fields such as history
ethnography
a law and civil rights and more
importantly the body will consist of
those who
understand how we as californians still
reap the consequences of
slavery both nationally and in our own
state
california's history with slavery is
often not well known
but between the statehood in 1850 and
the end of slavery in 1865
california though named a free state had
many
laws and rules and regulations that
basically made it a haven for slavery
uh california legislature authorized
southern slaveholders to hold persons in
bondage
so long as they entered the state under
an enslaved property state
we did not provide sanctuary to any
slave who ran who was basically seeking
freedom
in 1852 we adopted smoke the most harsh
fugitive slave law in the country
encompassing state and local
law enforcement or authorities to
enforce self-emancipated persons living
within the state back into slavery
the california supreme court ordered
fugitive slaves as it as in the case of
archie lee
to return to its enslavers in direct
violation of california's law
and until the end of the civil war
california city count and
county and law enforcement authorities
enforced
the fugitive slave law they enforced
also a contract labor system
that was no more than a slave holders
effort to maintain their slaves in
bondage
in other words california state county
and city authorities actively
supported the institution of lack of
black slavery both within
and beyond the war of the borders of
california
so this history is often not a part of
california's lore that we somehow never
believe that california was this free
state
and had no discrimination that existed
in the state of california
but it should be noted not only that
every attempt that has been made by
african americans to attain wealth
uh and enjoyed that was enjoyed by
others has been met with violence in
this nation
not only involved the black wall street
in oklahoma but also the allensworth
story
in california we have not only taken
away the good part we have taken not
only taking away the good part that
african-americans have started
but the campaign of terror met by
african-americans
has tactics such as fear-mongering
lynchings discriminatory voting
laws lower wages denied home ownership
and these tactics have led to
inequalities and and the reality in
california
according to governor newson in 2020
state of black cal
state of black uh california that we
make up only eight percent of
california's population yet we make a 43
of the homeless population in california
we also
uh make up only 85.6 of the male
population of california
yet we make up 28 of those who are
incarcerated black men who incarcerated
so the recent population
and also shows us by any indication that
african-american children despite the
fact that they have
been in california for many years
continue to
perform at the lowest level that's
possible and of course covet has
emphasized to all of us
the covet 19 just the disparities that
exist in california in terms of the
deaths
and the health system that has failed us
all in some the age of
enslavement both in california and
across the nation birth a legacy of
racial harm
and inequality that continues to impact
the conditions of black life
in california people have suffered
various injuries and losses
through the malicious culpability
negligence and conduct
of others that have the right to re and
we have the right to redress
interestingly enough and california has
we have had um
reparations in many areas throughout in
california in this nation
and yet none have felt the need to
provide it for african americans
the task force is currently being
established we hope that the
recommendations that will come forth
will be recommendations
that will begin to repair the damage
done to us in california
uh by no means does this mean that there
should not be federal reparations
in any sense the law the law clearly
states that but out of all due respect
californians can no longer wait for the
national government to do its job
we believe that we must do what is
necessary for californians and be an
example of what can happen this nation
when there is serious discussions and
research done on african americans and
the impact of slavery
we hope that the nation will join
california in forming a task force
to be able to address the issue of
reparations and the damage that has
been done and continues to be done as a
result of the engagement in slavery
thank you so very much
thank you madam secretary our our next
witness is and i'm going to
have to work with me on the
pronunciation tenday
aki oma if i'm wrong i apologize
she is a professor of law at ucla in the
u.n special rapporteur on contemporary
forms of racism racial discrimination
xenophobia and related intolerance her
work focuses on the global governance of
racism and xenophobia
and the legal and ethical implications
of colonialism for contemporary
international migration
more generally her research and teaching
interests lie in international human
rights law
international refugee law international
migration and property
she earned her jd and her ba from yale
university
and then moved on to the
sunny southern california professor you
are recognized for five minutes
thank you very much congress persons
it's a privilege to address you today
i'm a professor of law at ucla school of
law where i'm a core faculty member of
the promise institute for human rights
and the critical race studies program
and my areas of expertise include
international human rights law and the
global governance of racism
i'm also the united nations special
rapporteur on contemporary forms of
racism
racial discrimination xenophobia and
related intolerance
in this role i'm an independent expert
who's appointed to provide counsel to un
member states regarding among other
things
the meaning of their obligations under
international human rights law to combat
racism
racial discrimination and to promote
racial equality
my testimony today is drawn to a great
extent from a report i presented to the
united nations general assembly in 2019
on the urgency of reparations for racial
discrimination rooted in transatlantic
and colonialism international law
recognizes reparations
as necessary for rectifying wrongful
acts and providing accountability for
human rights violations
within the international legal system
reparations entail a specific framework
and responses
which i describe in full info in my
written testimony
but briefly within the system
reparations are defined broadly to
require restitution
compensation satisfaction rehabilitation
and guarantees of non-repetition
popular conceptions of reparations are
often fairly narrow
focusing only on financial compensation
but by contrast the international system
places emphasis on a more comprehensive
approach
according to which financial
compensation may certainly be necessary
but not sufficient
other required measures may include
transforming the political economic and
social institutions
and mechanisms for disclosing truth and
restoring dignity for those subject to
racial subordination
resulting from legacies of enslavement
notably general measures such as social
welfare programs that benefit racially
subordinated groups
including people of african descent that
are pursued in the ordinary conduct of
government
are not a substitute for reparations
fulfillment of state reparative
responsibilities
requires tailored interventions that are
rooted in acknowledgment of the
underlying harm
of violations these interventions seek
to remedy
in the context of racial discrimination
rooted in slavery
reparations addressed two sets of human
rights
first the historic racial injustices of
slavery that remain largely unaccounted
for today
and second the contemporary
discriminatory effects of structures of
inequality
and subordination that have resulted
from failures to redress
the racism of slavery and of colonialism
there's broad consensus in the
international community that the
abolition of the transatlantic slave
trade and slavery in general did not
terminate the racially discriminatory
structures
built by those practices and the
consensus is that transatlantic slavery
and colonialism remain among the root
causes of racism
racial discriminations xenophobia and
related intolerance against africans
and people of african descent as a
result
in addition to implicating individual
wrongful acts in the past
reparations for slavery implicate entire
legal
economic social and political structures
that enabled slavery and which continue
to sustain racial
discrimination and inequality today this
means that the urgent project
of providing reparations for slavery
requires governments not only to fulfill
remedial obligations
resulting from specific historic
wrongful acts
but also to transform contemporary
structures of racial injustice
and and of inequality and discrimination
that are the product of centuries of
slavery
national commissions such as those
proposed by hr 40
are well positioned to tailor
recommendations the specific legal
contexts
which sustain racial inequality in the
united states the history of
transatlantic slavery has left an
indelible mark
the continued presence of racism racial
discrimination
ideologies of racial superiority and
legal
in u.s legal political social and
economic structures
underscores the interconnection between
the historical wrongs of slavery and
contemporary injustices
i've joined other un experts in noting
that reparations are not just useful
mechanisms for fulfilling moral
or political obligations reparations for
slavery are an integral part of
fulfilling the international legal
mandate
to eliminate racial discrimination the
united states is not exempt from these
responsibilities
and hr 14 would represent important
progress and fulfilling
its obligations under international law
reparations for racial discrimination
rooted in the transatlantic slave trade
have proven controversial in the
countries that bear the greatest
responsibility for the associated
violation
in cases where states have pursued
reparations for slavery and colonialism
they have done so in racially
discriminated in racially discriminatory
ways
notable historical examples exist where
whites who have profited and benefited
for the most from chattel slavery and
colonialism
received monetary compensation while
non-whites and their nations were
partially or wholly left without redress
the reparations commission proposed by
hr-40 presents an opportunity for the
united states to show
international leadership on what can be
achieved when sufficient political will
exist to remedy historic and persisting
racial injustice
associated with the enslavement of
people of african descent
among the most significant barriers the
pursuit of reparations for people of
african dissenting in the united states
and elsewhere
is the absence of comprehensive
accounting of the harms of slavery
and the reparations commission would
provide the foundation for this
accounting thank you very much
thank you very much professor i
appreciate your your
lifelong studies and your work and your
passion and your participation
our next witness is kathy mussoka
miss masopa is co-chair of nikai
for civil rights and redress since 1971
she's worked on youth
workers housing and redress issues in
the little tokyo section of los angeles
she's a graduate of university of
california berkeley
uh my voice
good sir you're recognized
yes good morning good morning
chairperson ranking member of the
committee
and members of the committee the nikkei
for civil rights and redress
ncr and ak progressive supports hr 40
and the black community's demand for
reparations because
one it is the right thing to do two it
is long overdue
and three because we know it is possible
we won reparations in 1988
but japanese americans were not the
first to make that demand
the black community has long demanded
reparations
in 1963 queen mother audley moore the
mother of modern day reparations
movement
launched a campaign claiming back pay
for descendants of enslaved peoples
as well as job quotas and training
groups like the self-determination
committee formed in 1956
and along with the national coalition of
blacks for relations in america
and the national african-american
reparations committee have called for
reparations for the institution and
legacy of slavery
and hr 40 as you know has a long history
thanks to the congressman
late congressman john conyers even
before the civil war and since
emancipation
individual black americans fought for
and won limited reparations
our community's demand for reparations
did not arise by itself
but was inspired by the black
communities fight for civil and equal
rights and housing
education and more their sacrifices and
leadership opened the doors for us
and gave us the strength to demand
redress and reparations from the u.s
government
we have to acknowledge the generous
support of many black groups and
individuals who supported us in our
campaign for redress
by congressman mervin dimely who
authored a japanese-american regis bill
in 1982
representative ron dellums who spoke in
support of the bill
and the black congressional caucus and
many others including then california
assemblywoman
maxine waters and the reverend jesse
jackson h.r 40 is an important first
step towards
preparations for the black community in
1981 when the commission on wartime
relocation in terms of civilians
the cwric a commission to study if a
wrong had been committed was first
proposed
many of us including me or against it
angry that the injustice of the
concentration camps was even a question
but we soon understood that this was an
opportunity
for many former incarcerates to speak
out about their feelings and experiences
they had held inside
for 40 years so the community swung into
action
to mobilize testifiers for the hearings
ncrr
played a key role in organizing
grassroots support
within the japanese-american community
insisting that former incarcerates speak
at the hearings
instead of just having experts or
academics testify
many of the sansei third generation
japanese americans like myself and
children of the incarcerates
organized this effort we heard anger
sadness
pain and strength as we listen to
stories we have never heard before
none of us could stop listening it was
an opportunity to begin the healing
process for our elders
ourselves and for the entire community
more importantly it was a chance for
those incarcerated
to express their own demands for income
and freedom's loss
for babies who had died for dignity
taken away and much more
the hearings brought our east si nissi
and sansei
first second and third generations
together to build a grassroots campaign
educate others about the incarceration
and reach out to
other communities to win reparations
moreover the hearing solidified our
determination to hold our government
accountable
and to continue the campaign no longer
no matter
how long it took we saw individual
reparations
as a just accounting and not as a
handout
similarly h.r 40 is an opportunity for
all of us to learn about the institution
and legacy of slavery and its
destructive impact
that continues today on the black
community this is a chance for many
black voices to be heard
and for the black community to express
what kind of reparations
it is owed what we must do is listen
and learn from these stories from
broader historical context
to the most personal testimonies of pain
trauma and generational struggle
it was important for japanese americans
to determine our own path for redress
and reparations
and we fully stand behind the black
community as they determine their own
path forward
there is no dispute that the wealth of
this country was built on the stolen
lands
of the indigenous peace indigenous
people and on the free slave labor of
black people
in other words reparations are owed to
black people and to the indigenous
people
as guided by their communities the
movement for black lives tool kit
talks about reparations being owed in a
manner
and formed to be determined by black
people themselves
you must take as many forms as necessary
to equitably address
the many forms of injury caused by the
institution and legacy of slavery
h.r 40 is a necessary first steps
towards justice
is the first step towards healing thank
you very much
thank you miss misoka i appreciate your
your testimony and your
relating the experience of japanese
americans and african-americans
our next witness is mr herschel walker
mr walker is a former professional
football player college football player
athlete in general he played college
football at the university of georgia
and he won the 1982 heisman trophy
during his professional football career
that began in the united states football
league with the new jersey jets he
played for the dallas cowboys the nfl
the vikings the new york giants football
giants
and the philadelphia eagles he also
completed the 19
competed in the 1992 winter olympics as
a bobsledder
and has competed as a mixed martial
artist he was a supporter of president
trump in 2016 and 2020 spoke at the 2020
republican national convention
he holds a bachelor of science degree in
criminal justice studies from the
university of georgia
uh mr walker you'll be recognized for
five minutes at this
point i need to to go to the natural
resources committee for organizational
meeting and miss jackson lee if you're
there if you take the chair
for mr walker's testimony and until i
can return
miss jackson lee
yes sir mr chairman you're recognized mr
walker's been recognized and you are now
the
uh acting chair thank you ma'am mr
chairman i can't thank you enough for
your stupendous leadership
and friendship we will do this together
and again thank you for your
your history on all of this glad to work
with you and chairman nadler i just
wanted to interject that as you move to
your
other committee and i'm delighted to
listen to mr walker
thank you thank you
mr walker you're recognized
chairman and ranking members i thank you
for this opportunity
to speak on reparation which has been
spoken about
many times over my lifetime but over the
past year has become a hot topic
i asked the question why there's been
many surveys show
that a large percentage of black and
white teens would say racism is better
today than yesterday
whereas we use black power to create
white guilt
my approach is biblical how can i ask my
heavenly father to forgive me
if i can't forgive my brother i never
want to put anyone real
religion down but my religion teach
togetherness reparation teach separation
slavery in it over 130 years ago
how can a father be asked his son
to spend prison time for a crime he
committed
in the case we speak of research we're
researching farther back in history
a history of many are not taught or
spoken about
in school america is the greatest
country in the world to me
a melting pot a lot of great races a lot
of great minds that have come together
with different ideas and make america's
the greatest country in the earth on
earth
have many have died trying to get into
america
no one is dying trying to get out
reparation
where would the money come from does it
come for all the other races
except that blights taxpayers who is
black
what percentage of blight must you be to
receive reparation
do you go to 23 and mean or dna tests
to determine the percentage of blackness
some american ancestors just came to
this country 80 years ago
their ancestor wasn't even here during
slavery
some black immigrants weren't here
during slavery nor their ancestors
some states didn't even have slavery we
as black americans
have always wanted what the constitution
stated all men
blight white and today latino asian
italian
etc should be guaranteed the
aliability rights of life freedom
and the pursuit of happiness years later
after slavery ended
dr king i have a dream speech
said the sign the signing of the
emancipation proclamation
was a great beacon of light but hundreds
of years
later we're still not free because of
segregation and discrimination
today i call that reparation
i asked my mom who is in the mid 80s her
thought on reparation
her words i do not believe in reparation
who is the money going to go to has
anyone thought about paying the families
who lost someone in the civil war who
fought for their freedom
your dad and i taught you speaking of me
to
provide for you and your family through
a good education and hard work
if you give a man a fish you feed him a
day
you teach him to fish you feed him a
lifetime
reparation is only feeding you for a day
is removing the sign of for whites only
replacing the sign for no education here
black americans asking for a hand up not
a handout
another big question who is the guilty
party
should we start at the beginning where
african americans
sold your the african-american ancestors
into slavery
and to a slave trader who eventually
sold the african-american ancestors to
slave owners slave owners who had no
success
and no luck trying to make a native
america who land they took
become their slave because the native
american ran away
well they thought it was fine then
to use african-american who didn't know
the country
didn't know the language they know the
religion
and they didn't run away so i
asked why reparation
well
flavor is because
into the year 2021 still talking about
reparation not equal education
not to compare a game to a horrible
period in our in my life
but as i fought shoulder and shoulder
with my fellow football brothers
of other races i saw struggles they were
encountering the same as i
and i heard them speak to their parents
of problems
my family were dealing with as well if a
black player
would have been given something
different
than any other player it would have
created problems within the team
separation and division ezekiel 18 20
the righteousness of the right shall be
upon him
the son shall not suffer for the crime
of the father
nor the father suffer the crime of the
son unless
either father son know beforehand the
father or son was a criminal
to help any race provide them with a
good quality education
and help incentify through opportunities
with responsibilities
which helps generations in the future
if reparation is a free is it fee
or a correction for a terrible sin of
slave owners
government and others but we punish the
non-guilty
party if it is is it not creating
division a separation
with different races i feel it continues
to let us know
we're still african-american rather than
just american
reparation or atonement is outside
the teaching of jesus christ who you are
teaching who will not be teaching the
word of god
so i speak back
thank you very much mr walker for your
testimony
i'm delighted to now be able to
introduce our next witness
is mr cam howard mr howard is the
male co-chair of the national coalition
of blacks or reparations in america or
in cobra
if i might incover is a
founding father and mother of the
effort and the mission of
h.r 40 working early on with the late
dean of the united states congress john
conyers and continuing to work with over
300
organizations uh that are now standing
uh very effectively
in support of h.r 40 and cobra is a
mass-based coalition
of organizations and individuals
organized for the sole purpose
of obtaining reparations for persons of
african
descent in the united states he is a
chicago businessman
and real estate investor and a long-time
activist on the issue of reparations
and reparative justice i think it is
important to take note of the fact
uh that mr howard is a businessman
an investor but he's also someone who
understands
pulling yourself up by the bootstraps
works when you have boots
in 2015 as a member of the national
african-american reparations commission
he led a team